morning good morning merry christmas
celebrations taking place right across
the world today festivities have been
largely scaled back
but that hasn't stopped people gathering
at places of worship to mark the day at
the vatican pope francis has celebrated
christmas eve mass in front of an
estimated 1500 people
in saint peter's basilica the pontiff
urged the faithful to focus on the
littleness of jesus and to remember that
he came into the world poor those
attending mass were required to wear
face masks following new regulations
that all vatican staff must be
vaccinated
meanwhile bethlehem's manger square is a
wash with festive lights as hundreds
gathered to celebrate christmas there
nearly all of those are locals as israel
sadly has banned most flights from
overseas
midnight mass was held at the church of
nativity in bethlehem in the early hours
of this morning
celebrations were reduced due to covet
restrictions and concerns about the
omicron variant bethlehem hosted three
and a half million visitors during its
last pre-pandemic winter in
2019-20. archbishop of canterbury is set
to use his christmas sermon to preach a
message of support to volunteers helping
refugees
the most reverend justin welby is
expected to say that the christmas story
shows us how he must treat those who are
unlike us the archbishop who'll deliver
his sermon at canterbury cathedral at 11
o'clock this morning is also expected to
pay tribute to those volunteering at
food banks over the christmas period
and christmas in the southern hemisphere
sunny christmas day on sydney's bondi
beach for stranded expats huge crowds to
flock to sydney beaches as the city
turns on the hot weather for christmas
day a lot of bondi beach goers were seen
wearing santa hats with christmas picnic
spreads
here in the uk the queen is expected to
deliver a particularly personal
christmas day message her first since
the death of the duke of edinburgh her
majesty will celebrate christmas at
windsor instead of sandringham as is
traditional and because of the the
omicron variant she'll be joined by far
fewer members of the royal family
meanwhile the duchess of cambridge has
hosted together at christmas a carroll
concert at westminster abbey to pay
tribute to the people and organizations
who supported communities throughout the
pandemic here's melania
[Music]
a carol service with a difference hosted
by the duchess of cambridge at
westminster abbey
celebrating inspirational people who
help their communities get through this
difficult year we've been through such a
bleak time we've seen so many challenges
we've lost our loved ones we've seen our
frontline workers under immense pressure
and also we've been more emotionally and
socially distanced and isolated from
each other but i suppose through that
separation we've also realized how much
we need each other and how acts of
kindness and love can really bring us
comfort and relief in times of distress
the duchess showcased her piano skills
in public for the first time in a
surprise performance with singer tom
walker it was amazing uh she was you
know she's a really talented musician
um i think there was a bit of
nervousness from both of us when we were
initially planning it and we did a
rehearsal together and it was the first
time she'd played with another musician
in over 10 years
uh i think during lockdown the duchess
played a lot of piano to kind of
get through and
distract herself from everything um but
yeah it was amazing it went so well
the event capped off a difficult year
for the royal family marked by the death
of prince philip whose photograph with
the queen took center stage during her
christmas message and in a tender
tribute the monarch wore the same
sapphire brooch she first donned as a
newlywed
for anybody spending christmas without
the person they'd spent the whole of
their lives with will be tough i think
the the emblem of the bridge that she's
wearing
is so special and typical of her
recognition of the fact that he's still
with her in spirit
the queen usually hosts her family on
her sandringham estate but yet again the
virus scuppered the festive gathering
this is the second year the queen will
spend christmas at windsor castle
because of covid and the first to spend
without her husband in a very long time
but she won't be alone she'll be joined
by the prince of wales and the duchess
of cornwall on christmas day
on the queen's christmas tree are 100
stars
your stars that you made were made by
the children from the royal school in
windsor we made stars and they went on
the queen's christmas tree
and the queen loved it yeah
she did
a symbol of hope that next christmas
will be better for all of us
milena vasselinovich sky news
she looks great doesn't she apparently
she was wearing red um to be a little
bit more um upbeat and
lifting the spirits of the nation we'll
hear from her majesty i think at three
o'clock this afternoon for the queen's
speech just after you've had your turkey
and the first row now families across
the country as i said celebrating um a
second christmas sadly in the shadow of
the pandemic as the expectation of
further covet restrictions
in the next few weeks
are looming thousands across the country
self-isolating today charities working
harder than ever to deliver supplies to
those of us spending the day alone
particularly because christmas eve saw
the highest number of new cases of the
virus since the start of the pandemic it
comes as modeling by government
scientific advisers see we're leaving
her there just to keep your mood a
little bit uh lifted today because you
know this stuff from the university of
warwick suggesting new coveted
restrictions similar to those in place
in england in april might be necessary
until late march to reduce the number of
kobe deaths in the new year that's
despite early studies showing a much
lower risk of hospitalization from
omicron compared to other variants
here's sadia
i'm just going to put the um
food parcel for you
christmas milk it's delivery for those
self-isolating with covid all right
thank you you've got chicken you've got
turkey and you've got a christmas dinner
that's already cooked this community in
east london wants to make sure nobody
feels alone
from our own parents and people around
your neighbors and everything that
sometimes they don't have the connection
with the family
their children either because they moved
away too far or they've passed away or
something
or they're just on their own so we feel
it's really important to cheer people up
and
let people know that the community is
there for them
the crates are fully loaded so that
those self-isolating won't feel the need
for a trip to the supermarket
scientists warn rules must be taken
seriously especially at christmas
self-isolating is incredibly important
the only real way we can beat this is by
breaking chains of infection people can
reduce their risk by standing at a
distance from other people they might
not really want to do that around
christmas but i think it's a good idea
this year many more of us will spend
christmas alone as covered cases soar
over a hundred and twenty thousand new
cases of covid were recorded in the
latest 24-hour period that's a new
record high
and it means that nearly three-quarters
of a million people are likely to be
self-isolating today and that's along
with the million or so who are recently
bereaved and almost a million who
whether self-isolating or not
don't have anyone to spend christmas
with
the scale of need has only increased
our calls to our helpline doubled and
they've sustained at that level ever
since
the numbers of people seeking help and
support has continued to go up
a reading from the letter to titus at
midnight mass in southwark cathedral a
chance for a few to come together
extra special perhaps this year knowing
how
just want to have a quick look at the
booster figures uh for you this morning
this is what happened yesterday 605 000
people more actually um had either the
booster or their third jab
that means that nearly 32.3 million
people have now had their third jab or
booster and um we are going to go to a
booster center a little bit later on
because they're even open
today so if you're going for a walk
you've not had your booster yet leave
the dog outside pop in and have your
booster not just for you but for
everybody else around you all now
how do we tackle loneliness
among the elderly at christmas i'm going
to be speaking to charities making sure
no one feels alone this festive season
that's at half past seven
not just the elderly of course will
speak to a samaritan's volunteer as
hundreds of thousands of people are
forced to isolate this christmas because
they've tested positive
and heading to church this morning find
out how you can stay covered safe at
christmas services
um also making the news for you today
commercial airlines around the world
have cancelled more than four and a half
thousand flights over the christmas
weekend because of a surge in coveted
infections the disruptions have caused
uncertainty and misery for holiday
travelers
flight tracking website flightaware.com
says at least uh 2
400 flights were cancelled yesterday
typically a busy day for air travel
10 000 more flights were delayed around
a quarter of the cancellations were in
the us
technology designed to look into the
origins of the universe is set to launch
into space later the james webb
telescope which will replace hubble has
been designed with the help of british
scientists it's able to look back 13
billion years to the oldest stars and
will orbit around 1 million miles from
earth it'll also investigate whether
planets outside our own solar system may
be suitable for life
now former england striker daniel
sturridge has been ordered to pay thirty
thousand dollars to a man who found his
missing dog sturridge offered a reward
for the return of the pomeranian named
lucci in july of 2019 the pooch was
found by a local musician foster
washington the court documents show a
default judgment was given meaning
sturridge did not answer the
complaint when afghanistan fell to the
taliban in august of this year among
those
most desperate to flee the country were
the female judges lawyers and
prosecutors who were vital in upholding
the rights of african women and girls
over the last two decades more than a
hundred female judges and their families
managed to escape with the help of a
team of lawyers here in the uk
ashna has been speaking to the british
lawyer who helped coordinate her escape
falzia was a trailblazer in afghanistan
as one of the first women to climb the
ladder in the judiciary only a senior
judge in the supreme court gets an
office like this
we work on the elimination of violence
against women in afghanistan in our
courts
for almost 20 years she fought violence
against women won domestic abuse cases
and shaped family law in afghanistan
but in august the taliban dismantled it
all
the legal system scrapped and those like
fauzia forced into hiding
i'm very sad now
because the our judicial system is not
better now
it's it's sadly for me it's for my
another judges also very sadly
the humanitarian rescue effort was
desperate hundreds of lawyers needed to
flee
choreographing the escape thousands of
miles away was baroness kennedy the
women who were contacting me were
terrified of their lives they were
hiding with their families and their
children in basements um they had moved
out of their houses and gone to stay
with relatives
um and they were getting these threats
on their phones and then through
relatives it would be receiving threats
and so so i i mean it was really
it was it was it was the horror of all
of that that made us think um at the
institute of human rights we've got to
do something
through donations a team of pro bono
lawyers chartered flights to rescue the
judges and their families over a hundred
were brought to safety australia and
ireland among the countries taking them
in
baroness kennedy says these women can
play a part in the legal system here
these are wonderful people who were
doing good things for us
and protecting the rule of law trying to
build a new democracy there and who were
basically dealing with you know
dealers in heroin and dealing with men
who were abusing women and the stuff
that we care about and that we lead the
world on
and falzia wants to be one of them
we are safe now and all
my family save my children
and my husband also
i want to study and work here
because i want to my
specialist i'm a judge and i want to
work
here now grateful
safe and now many willing to use their
legal minds in their new home
ashna harinag sky news
now many of us will be getting together
with the loved ones to eat our christmas
lunch but how can we do it safely
joining us now our regular gp dr david
lloyd to give us a few tips on a covid
secure christmas hello to you doc i
suppose the first thing you'd say is if
you've not had your booster go and get
one
dollar yes and i i think there are
actually places that are open on
christmas day where you can so yes that
is a a very good suggestion uh yes
and as far as um our elderly relatives
are concerned if we're lucky enough to
have um elderly relatives what can we do
to look after them
so i think we've just got to be very
aware i'm so sorry on this on this you
know very special day to talk about
these things but uh
i guess that we've got to be aware of
the symptoms of cobit and also make sure
that we're not carrying the virus so i
was i would say any
any
meeting should be preceded i'm afraid by
a lateral flow test uh and just watch
out for the symptoms because as you know
uh over the year we've been talking you
always know far more than me but the the
symptoms of covid seem to have changed
something so it's a runny nose it's a
sore throat and it's a headache rather
than the classic fever
uh cough and loss of sense of smell so
things have changed so if you've got any
of those symptoms you should be very
suspicious that you might be carrying
this virus
what do you make of the latest research
um which is suggesting i know you've
been on holiday so i'll share it with
you um the omicron variant from the uk
um
health security agencies saying that the
um
the symptoms and and what it might do to
you are significantly less severe than
the previous delta variant
yes i think that's what i've been
picking up uh but it and and it seems to
be
moving up the airway if you like the the
pneumonia from the first delta covid
seems to be moving up so it's a more of
an upper respiratory infection which
which is good news i mean i mustn't get
too excited but it is good news it may
be that the virus is becoming less
virulent as it learns to live with us
because that's the virus doesn't want to
kill us really it wants to have a host
that stays alive so they can go on
living and breeding so
so yes it is
a a good uh
a a good thing that these symptoms seem
to have changed i'm going to get shot
down by saying living viruses do do
viruses live that's a very good question
i don't know
don't they they do yes they need a host
yeah um talk to me something that um i
often think about at this time of year
when i first came to london a very long
time ago a very long time ago um i was
working at christmas and so i had
christmas day on my own and ever since
i've always had waves and strays anybody
who's on their own comes to my house for
christmas
a lot of people are still on their own
at christmas time and and i suppose it
is a health issue in that you know
that's when people can be down and very
sad and it's really important isn't it
to make sure that we just go and knock
on the door and make sure everybody's
okay
so important i think yes i think we've
got to be very aware of the other
consequences of being alone
and the consequences of being alone at
christmas so yes a very good point okay
we've got to look after our own and make
sure that people who are living on their
own who may be having a horrid time at
christmas uh get a little bit of cheer
that would be great
and you've just been away haven't you
how difficult was it to travel at the
moment did you find it fairly
straightforward
astonishingly straightforward yes i i
breeze through malaga airport and i
breeze through uh london heathrow so yes
and i've had my pcr it was all very
slick so yes it was all right for me but
i gather that
thousands of flights being cancelled so
i do feel very sorry for people who are
hanging around for hours in different
places so yes no it was very easy but
you're gonna be able to spend christmas
with family
yes provided their lateral flows are
negative of course i'm pcr negative so
i'm i'm feeling i'm crowing today
yeah i know exactly what you mean merry
christmas doctor it's lovely to see you
thank you very much enjoy your christmas
thank you
very quick look at the weather for you
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
low pressure in the atlantic pushing
rain into the country from the southwest
bringing mild conditions but cold air
still sits over the north and the
northeast big question
is it's going to be a white christmas
the answer is if you're living on a hill
in scotland probably
for the rest of us know
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
thank you for all the pictures that you
are sending lorry drivers in their camps
we'll share those with you later on i
was also asking for christmas baby
pictures yesterday look at this cutie uh
sarah sent us a picture of her
granddaughter arya rose beautiful name
on twitter she was born
four weeks early at the end of july but
she is an absolute cutie i love her hat
how cool is that
let's have a look at baby archie
central's by sue on twitter who's also
five months old born in july
and look at this one anne-marie sent us
pictures of her granddaughters
there they are
seven week old sylvian iris who is 16
weeks old uh so do send us uh more of
your pictures of the little ones who are
dressed up in their christmas finery
tweet me directly if you would like to
at k burley umar standing by to make
sure we put those on the telly and share
them with the world which is exactly
what santa is trying to do over the
previous and the next few hours there he
is
where is he
he's on the other side
of the planet and um
i think i'm being told he's now over the
uh pacific to be specific um and there
is on his santa app he's heading towards
mexico is what i'm being told
there he is so if you're in mexico
watching us in cancun
or whatever
um then he's heading your way and um oh
yeah actually san diego there you go san
diego california united states in 39
seconds he's going to be with you so if
you're not in bed go now kids go now
otherwise he won't stop there we are
santa with all the reindeer i was saying
yesterday look at all the radio with
their antlers now they're called rudolph
et cetera aren't they did you know
that their ladies exactly kevin my
director because only lady reindeer have
their antlers in the wintertime
there you go something new you learn
every single day you are watching our
breakfast program on christmas morning
for you trying to keep everything upbeat
for you if you're watching us and you're
on your own this morning don't go
anywhere we'll try and brighten your day
as well and we'll be talking to some
people that can help you with that
[Music]
hello again everybody a very merry
christmas we wherever you are watching
us around the world today i've had
messages from singapore and los angeles
so far this morning we've got some
pictures that you would like to share
with us of you with your family
celebrating christmas wherever you are
then do send them to us and we will
share them with the rest of the world
you can tweet me directly if you would
like to at k burley not everybody has
got family and friends with them have
they though at this christmas time you
need to
think about the elderly in particular
who might find themselves um on their
own morgan vine head of policy
independent age is with us hi morgan
good morning to you merry christmas
merry christmas what do we need to do to
look after the elderly obviously we're
going to be quite concerned that we
don't want to give them any infections
or anything at this time of year
absolutely i mean i think there's small
things that people can do just checking
in phone calls safe visits if you know
you're down their door path etcetera so
at a safe distance not to infect anybody
and but there's also things like
charities like us so national and local
charities exist in most localities that
support older people who are feeling
lonely and isolated so whether you put
the older person you know in touch with
those charities or whether you've got
time to volunteer yourself and some of
those volunteering opportunities can be
not very time consuming others more so
so you know you can pick and choose
depending on what you've got time for
yeah now what about people who are at
home
and they are on their own and they're
feeling very lonely because you know we
we have these images of everybody around
the tree et cetera et cetera i've done
three or four isolations this year
either because i've had covid or you
know i've had to have tests or whatever
and it's horrible
is there anything we can do
to um
so advice we can give to people to
perhaps break through that apart from
binge watching netflix
i mean i think one thing is thinking
about who they might have lost contact
with and whether they want to give them
a call and obviously phoning somebody
isn't going to put you at more risk to
the virus
and there's lots of people who would be
really open to receiving that phone call
and happy to get it
at independent age which is the charity
i work for for example we run telephone
friendship groups so we have older
people who come together on a weekly
basis
in small groups and chat about anything
from gardening to cooking and to
memories of being on holiday so there's
lots of activities like that that people
could get involved with
the elderly never want to be any trouble
today so how do we know if they're
feeling lonely
i think it's best just to ask or even if
you don't want to put the focus on the
fact that somebody might be feeling
lonely because that can obviously make
somebody feel quite vulnerable or they
might not want to say just bring them up
and see how they are and you don't have
to you know flag that you think they
might be feeling low or blue you can
just see how they're doing tell them
what you're up to and i think often that
can be just as effective how has the
rising cost of living impacted um on
people feeling lonely particularly the
elderly yes at independent age we've
been talking to people throughout the
pandemic about their worries and
concerns and we did a survey um in the
autumn actually of about 5 000 people
and a quarter of them said they were
really really worried about cost of
living rises so we sort of followed that
up over the last few weeks and some of
the findings are really concerning so um
older people were telling us that they
were gonna cut back on their bills like
reduce their electricity and their gas
and at a time when we all know it's cold
and dark that's not something that you
know we would want people to feel forced
into doing and so people are having to
make really tough choices and i think
what's really important is for the older
age group there are less ways that they
can tackle cost of living or increase
their income it's not like they can go
off and get a new job if they're in
their 80s or 90s for example so they
have to manage on what they've got and
that's why we're really worried about it
i mean people often have these
assumptions about older people that
they're you know in retirement living on
vast incomes but actually two million
live in poverty
and you know when we speak to people
that's them making choices about
not getting fresh fruit not putting the
kettle on more than once a day um
sleeping in a hat and a coat and things
like that
wow
how do people uh get in touch with your
agency if they want to be involved with
the phone groups that you're talking
about and the like so independent age
we've got lots of information and
support on our website both about the
telephone groups but also if you are
feeling lonely or if you want to support
somebody who's lonely and so our website
is independentage.org
and our telephone number which is open
at various points over the next few days
and we'll go back to full fully being
open um in the new year is oh 800 319
6789 okay uh omar will um cut a clip of
our interview put it on uh twitter and
we'll make sure that we have that um
telephone number there as well merry
christmas thank you for joining us thank
you
not just the elderly of course who can
feel um a bit alone at christmas time
let's talk to nikos susurus who is from
the charity the smile
brigade um hello to you um
talk to me about the smile brigade
hi good morning merry christmas well the
small brigade is a very lovely community
organization based in hammersmith and
fulham
which has been going in different forms
for the
past decades and
before the pandemic we were helping all
the people in vulnerable and at risk
residents
with the health and well-being with
activities entertainment
since the pandemic we've moved to uh
food delivery services so anyone who is
at risk vulnerable especially all the
people uh would deliver food straight to
the doors at no cost to them uh food and
groceries we've done hundreds of
thousands of meals over amazing 20
months and uh of course christmas is the
biggest
um event for us and i'm sure yeah so
what will you be doing today nicholas
uh today i've been doing what i've been
doing over the past week what many of us
have been doing over the past week which
will be preparing and delivering food
and gifts for free to
i think today it's more than 400
residents across hammersmith and fulham
mainly elderly people um
but anyone who is at risk or vulnerable
that's amazing and what would how would
you celebrate christmas you're gonna
have a little bit of time for yourself
as well
uh
once we're done i think i have some time
to catch up on some sleep uh
unfortunately the plans fell through uh
but uh yeah no uh boxing day is probably
the one for some time for myself
okay well you have um i mean great work
that you do goodness me all those people
are eating because you and your team are
there to help them good for you thank
you so much for taking a few minutes out
to talk to us here on sky news this
morning thank you very much thank you
merry christmas
now
after a century and a half hidden away
in private collections 13 stolen
ethiopian artifacts have finally
returned home following months of
negotiation the artifacts were looted by
british soldiers in the 19th century if
you're in greece look away now you know
what i mean scholars say their return to
ethiopia could be the best way to
reflect that we're coming to terms with
the more complicated aspects of british
colonial past as john reports
the people of ethiopia
have been around for a long long time
this region has been populated for
thousands of years
but the country's ancient heritage isn't
immediately apparent in the capital
addis ababa
[Music]
yet there is a place in this city where
some of ethiopia's most precious
artifacts are stored
and they have recently received some
very important additions three of them
came from the netherlands yeah and 13 of
them from britain okay
we were taken to the fourth floor of the
national museum storeroom and they
unlocked a cabinet in the corner
inside we found cultural treasures
looted by british soldiers in the 19th
century oh wow what what is that it's a
shield it's a shield yes
and was that used in the battle of
magdala yeah earlier this year these
items were put up for auction by the
descendants of the troops who took them
but ethiopian diplomats intervened and
negotiated their return to the capital
you can see the name of the captain who
who took it
the british soldier who grabbed these
buffalo horn beakers topped them in
silver and engraved his name
is it disappointing that family members
are doing this they're trying to make
money out of
stolen items yeah disappointing
disappointing not because that is that
particular family auctioned them but
because these are part of ethiopian
treasures which auctioned in the outside
world
the battle of magdala in 1868 is viewed
by many ethiopians as a catastrophe
facing defeat by the british army
emperor theodore ii took his own life
and his possessions were expropriated
some of them ended up in museums and
others ended up in private collections
of the soldiers and the soldiers also
when they found theodore's body
they took cut bits of his hair and
ripped bits of his his shirt and
souvenirs
and in fact quite recently the imperial
war museum returned restituted a
a piece of his hair
the then minister of culture went on a
visit and she
pointed out to them that it was
not really such a nice thing to do to
have
human remains on display
in europe and the uk
people feel less comfortable now about
cultural treasures that were plundered
at gunpoint and it's prompted some to
act a cambridge college has returned one
of the famed benin bronzes stolen by
british soldiers back in 1897
and the french president emmanuel macron
says he's prepared to return all
artifacts that were taken without
consent
but such a policy would devastate
collections in institutions like the
british museum british cultural
institutions museums have provided a
safe space
to both preserve and display
these items that they have essentially
ensure their survival that's correct but
let's not forget that um manuscripts
have been kept in ethiopia from the
sixth century and uh you know they even
had a system where they had cats that
were
there to protect the churches and the
manuscripts from rats
ethiopians have not forgotten about the
theft of a set of christian plaques at
the battle of magdala
each church in this country has one
they're called tablets but the tablets
removed from the battlefield are of deep
historical and holy importance the
public at large now still frequently
asked
primarily the tablets and that is very
sacred project very sacred the tabots
which represent the ark of the covenant
are now held in a storeroom in the
british museum and 20 years of
negotiations has not won their release
it's uh even it's it's it's really just
shocking
these artifacts come with their own
unique history a record of theft that
cannot be ignored
and pressure will build on those who
hold them to return them
it may be the best way to learn from the
past
john sparks sky news in addis ababa
south african cabinet minister urging
the cancellation of an upcoming american
auction of a key to the robin island
prison cell where nelson mandela was
jailed sale is due in january in new
york by guernsey's auction house the
seller is christobrand mandela's former
prison guard in the notorious jail south
africa's culture minister said there had
been no consultation with the government
that he belongs to the people of south
africa and is not anyone's personal
belonging
many of those
faced difficult personal uh financial or
physical challenges during the pandemic
had an impact on their mental health and
with uk kobe cases hit the highest level
since the pandemic began there are more
concerns about the effects of mental
health let's talk more about it should
we steve's joining us from the
samaritans hi steve thanks for joining
us oh what a year what two two years
it's been um
how are people
coping in your experience
hi steve can you hear me
steve we're going to come back to you in
just a sec we can't hear you just at the
moment we'll come back to you in just a
minute
meantime
i don't know if you were listening a
little bit earlier on i was talking to
you um about truckers and you remember
earlier on in the year when we were
saying christmas would be ruined we
wouldn't have the food that we needed
for christmas
and lots of gifts that we'd ordered
would not be coming laurie drivers
really really pulled out all the stops
didn't they including steve there's
steve and steve sent me this picture and
he reminded me last night of all of the
lorry drivers who've been working so
hard
over the last few weeks to make sure
that we can all celebrate at christmas
with our loved ones
if you have got a picture of yourself as
a trucker in the cab send them to us you
can tweet me directly if you would like
to at k burley and we will share them
with the world
mean time look at this the biden
family's new puppy spent part of
christmas eve playing on the lawn of the
white house there he is he's called
commander
there he was doing what dogs do chasing
a ball he's also with his owner there
the nearly four-month-old german
shepherd enjoyed the day with peter neal
the fiancee of president joe biden's
granddaughter naomi the biden's other
dog another german shepherd named major
now lives off-site with family friends
you know why don't you because he bit
somebody um there he is welcome
commander
let's see if we can speak to steve now
hi steve
morning hello ah you're there sorry
about that steve yeah christmas gremlins
you know what they're like that's
another movie i like to watch at
christmas time um a lot of people
sad at this time of year they've gone
through the whole year and they may be
finding themselves on their own at
christmas time um
talk to us about how you help them
well i mean we know we're there it's
important to remember that we're there
24 hours a day seven days a week every
day of the year anyways so christmas is
is another day but of course i think
we're acutely aware of the fact that for
for many people it's not a happy time it
can be a a really lonely and isolated
time and a time where people can you
know reflect on on happy family times
they may have had in the past and don't
have any more so i think it's important
that we're there uh just to make sure
that they know that there is a
connection there there are people around
that that you know are there to talk to
to um
to to basically share things with on a
day like this which as i said is
sometimes not the happiest of days no um
is it a busy time of year for you
uh well
interestingly enough i mean i don't
think there is a busy time of the year
it's always busy so uh
christmas is no different to any other
day of the year really we we we take
i think the the statistic is at the
moment it's a call every seven seconds
um and that's 24 hours a day goodness
yeah 24 hours a day every day of the
week and every day of the year you know
so we are constantly busy i think the
need for our services is always there
yeah why did you decide to volunteer
steve
um we had a family tragedy a member of
our family um
sadly took their own lives and um and so
we uh myself and my partner carolyn felt
compelled to do something she approached
it from the uh the side of of becoming a
spokesperson for
suicide awareness and these kind of
things and i um decided that i wanted to
do something as well and so i joined
samaritans about seven years ago now
um for the simple fact that i wanted to
give something back you know in in that
situation so yeah that's uh that's
that's the reason amazing amazing work
that you guys do a call every seven
seconds though oh my goodness me thanks
for joining us steve um love to you mrs
as well and um have a merry christmas
thank you so much you too thank you very
much thank you thanks a lot anyone who
is affected by the topics that we have
been discussing or is emotionally
distressed can reach out to the
samaritans for support at the number on
the screen for you now
116-123 we'll leave that up for you
kevin won't we or via email you go to
joe at
samaritans.org you're not on your own
you know the and don't feel that it's
just you just hearing there from steve a
call every seven seconds give them a
ring or even better if you know someone
who might be on their own at the moment
pop round you don't you can keep a safe
distance just leave a present on the
doorstep we'll see in a sec
[Music]